bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
tous sur rt france alors tout d'abord
pourquoi cette lettre cette lettre et
qu'attendez-vous précisément du ministre
des affaires étrangères le guen nous
avons écrit c'est peut-être parce que
victimes ans après un an après le
rapport des nations unies et il a l'air
de nombreuses ong décoller comme
sébastien nadeau qui moutinot talent un
david avait interpellé le 2 ministres et
un an plus tard en fait en sommes
toujours au même point et il ya un
article de notre confrère louis imbert
dans le monde
il ya un peu plus d'une semaine qui
rappellent qu'ils rappellent les choses
et nous nous souhaitons que la france
que le gouvernement puisse effectivement
interrogées sont des alliés les émirats
arabes unis sur cette situation quand
même assez particulière ou un site
gazier de liquéfaction de gaz donc dont
total est l'actionnaire majoritaire et
qui avait bénéficié il ya dix ans au
moment de la création du site du
garanties de crédit de la france de 216
millions d'euros cash aujourd'hui nous
savons nous savons depuis l'année
dernière que c'est que ça a été investie
par l'armée les émirats arabes unis qui
vous le savez est l'allié de l'arabie
saoudite et et du gouvernement yéménite
dans dans la guerre qui oppose le
gouvernement aux rebelles houthi et nous
savons grâce au rapport des nations
unies et des ong que c'est que ce site
dont total est le principal actionnaire
aujourd'hui servent de prisons secrètes
à deux bases militaires et de prisons
secrètes et il y à défaire arrive avérée
de torture et donc c'est évidemment par
une équipe qui a un site qui appartient
à un groupe français servent de prison
et de centres de torture pour l'armée
generali et sans sentiment que c'est un
million d'euros en prison pour les nra
les cetc d'une garantie de crédit en
tout cas effectivement il ya bien c'est
un groupe privé français qui a bénéficié
du soutien de l'état pour effectivement
une usine qui aujourd'hui vont elles ne
sert pas c'est pas de la faute
au total sa a été réquisitionnés dans le
cadre d'une guerre mais c'est quand même
un vrai sujet donc aujourd'hui il se
passe qui ment des crimes de guerre des
actes de torture avéré par les nations
unies a avéré par des ong sur un site
effectivement qui qui appartient à un
groupe un groupe privé français donc la
moindre des choses c'est que le
gouvernement français qui ça interrogé
son allié les émirats arabes unis vous
le savez qui avec l'arabie saoudite sont
les alliés de la france la france bambou
de beaucoup de plus en plus d'armes
pardon à l'arabie saoudite et aux
émirats et ya un vrai sujet là dedans
c'est que celle des émirats arabes unis
se pose comme ultime en une force on va
dire stabilisatrice dans la région de
lutte contre l'islam politique alors que
pour le goût au yémen elle est plutôt
une force déstabilisatrice où elle
soutient des factions contre d'autres et
notamment des groupes salafistes
islamistes radicaux ont synthétisé
nairas soit un des plus gros qui ont de
la france en ce qui concerne la vôtre
dame est ce que vous devrez sacré chez
l'industrie de la défense pour une
maison
il s'agit effectivement on peut
interroger aussi le fait que l'on gagne
de plus en plus d'armes aux émirats
arabes unis puisque entre mai 2010 et
2010 deux fonds on a vendu pour 4 7
milliards d'euros d'armes et et ses 1,5
milliards sur la seule année 2009
bon ça c'est un vrai sujet mais dans une
guerre qui est une sale guerre comme
comme jean yves le drian lui-même l'a
qualifié
on parle peuvent effectivement du
conflit est bénite
mais pourtant les nations unies l'ont
qualifié de pire catastrophe humanitaire
aujourd'hui oui donc effectivement il ya
sept ans cette ce soutien à interroger
mais de dire que demander où il ya même
des explications aux émirats arabes unis
des explications sur l'utilisation de ce
site comme comme prisons secrètes où
sont avérés des actes de torture ce
n'est pas complètement remettre en cause
la relation de la france avec les
émirats arabes unis mais c'est la
moindre des choses des choses
effectivement de demander des
explications
merci beaucoup en tout cas les berges
julien-laferrière d'avoir réagi sur ce
sujet sur rt france je rappelle que vous
êtes un député l'écologie démocratie
solidarité de la première
circonscription du rhône ans